amid uncertainty on how long europe's
covered pandemic will last greece has a
solution to get
tourists flocking to its resorts again
the prime minister wants the eu to
to urgently agree a way for vaccinated
travelers
to cross borders freely it is urgent to
adopt a common understanding about how
vaccination certificates should be
structured so they can be accepted in
all member states
well covered passports are being
suggested by other states too in poland
for example vaccinated people will be
sent qr codes to exempt them from
social distancing rules those who've had
the shot can also use public services
without extra testing
airlines are also latching on to this
idea a survey for australia's qantas
does show that nine out of ten people
would get inoculated so they can travel
again
but more than half a year of talks
around the world have so far failed to
agree a
cross-border deal and the head of the
world travel and tourism council does
say that people that haven't had the job
should also
be allowed to travel too the wh show
is totally against health passports okay
and we believe uh that as well because
that can lead to discrimination
unfortunately the vaccine is not
available everywhere there are a lot of
developing countries that they still
don't have
access to the vaccine we don't see it as
the only solution as vaccination
should not be the only consideration
currently
we have a limited supply and we need to
prioritize the vulnerable groups
we don't have to wait for a vaccine to
travel well
at the same time people can still travel
as long as you have for instance if
you're coming from a
destination with high cases of kobe to a
destination with lower cases of coping
it would be helpful to present and this
is what we have been asking
a test negative for covet so that you're
allowed to board the plane
with a testing massive testing
implemented
before boarding or before flying what we
say is a digital
certificate or a paper certificate
should be fine the only reason
why the digital certificate is stronger
is because you avoid
corruption or you avoid fake
certificates but a paper certificate
should also be
fine we believe that a digital
certificate of having a negative test
should be fine enough and we truly
believe that we have to protect the
health
information for the traveler and for
people
in general
you